hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the state of 4k in early
2016. so remember how in the last state
of 4k video i said that i couldn't tell
how many of you guys are clicking that
wrench to watch these videos in full
2160p 4k
well
i still can't but google analytics does
now tell me what the screen resolution
of everyone watching mkbhd videos is so
i have a full list from top to bottom of
the most popular screen resolutions of
people watching mkbhd videos so in the
last month the number one most common
display resolution to watch one of my
videos is 1920 by 1080 so 1080p display
coming in at 25
the next most common was 1366 by 768
followed by 1280 by 800 then 1440 by 900
you have to go all the way down to 36th
to find the first 4k display 3840 by
2160 at 0.11 so just a tenth of one
percent of you even have the ability to
watch in 4k if you wanted to
despite that i still think the state of
4k here in 2016 is very strong when
looking at the state of 4k you consider
these three things recording 4k
streaming 4k
and displaying 4k recording in 4k has
never been better there is 4k cameras
everywhere now from the high-end video
gear and production stuff the video
you're watching right now is definitely
4k all the way to the dslr's and the
camcorders and the mirrorless and even
the point-and-shoots and pocket cameras
all the way down to the smartphones most
smartphones from the past year or two
have 4k cameras in there with all the
millions of iphone 6s out in the wild
the number of 4k cameras in people's
pockets today has never been higher so
pretty much anyone can record 4k video
now for watching 4k it's actually also
never been better it's not quite as
widespread as the ability to record 4k
like everyone has a smartphone but
pretty much everyone who makes a tv now
has some sort of affordable 4k panel
available and all the tvs you're seeing
in these store shelves and in displays
are 4k you can definitely still buy a
1080p tv but the price difference is
shrinking pretty quick and then besides
tvs there's all the other screens in our
lives which are approaching 4k if not
quite there yet we see a bunch of 4k
laptops out there in the wild now this
is dell's xps 15. it's a full 4k laptop
and there's other 4k laptops from razer
toshiba asus acer they're definitely out
there but you will also definitely pay
premium for these super high-res
displays most people aren't buying 4k
laptops yet and really the smaller you
go with 4k the more expensive and rare
it is there's exactly one 4k smartphone
in the world right now and that's the
sony xperia z5 premium and i've even
talked about in a whole entire dedicated
video why it's not even really a
full-time 4k smartphone it's 4k capable
but at least it exists you have some
super high resolution tablets out there
but again the 4k ones aren't really
showing up in stores yet so at a smaller
level at the pocket level it's pretty
rare to have people carrying around a 4k
display in their pocket but as you get
bigger as you move up to stuff like
laptops you start to see more and then
you get bigger stuff like the 5k imac
and your 4k desktop displays those are
more common and then 4k tvs are
everywhere so recording 4k is easy
displaying 4k is
getting there so the focus now shifts to
the bottleneck which is right in between
it's streaming 4k actually getting 4k
video to play on your 4k screen now if
you want to watch your own 4k video
that's easy you just plug it into your
4k tv and you're good to go but if you
want to watch someone else's 4k video or
a 4k movie or a tv show or live tv
then it gets a little bit more
complicated that is definitely still a
work in progress youtube is still the
best in my opinion as far as supporting
4k video goes like i said this video
here is available in 4k you can hit that
wrench and watch it in 2160p if you want
you might not have a 4k display you
might not have a super fast internet
connection you might not even have a
graphics card that'll let you watch 4k
video but youtube will still let you do
it vimeo also added 4k support in the
past year and netflix is another one of
those sites that's continuing to offer
more and more of their shows in 4k when
they can but like live broadcast tv is i
feel like always going to be like one
step behind it's super hard to upgrade
like if i want to shoot 4k video i just
upgrade the camera or if i want to watch
4k video i just upgrade to a 4k tv but
if i want to watch 4k live tv often that
requires digging up cables in the ground
connecting new wires outside like this
is just something that people don't
really want to bother with and haven't
for the past couple years and 2016 still
might not be that time for live tv it's
still about the quality of the pixels
not the number of them so 1080p tv is
still a staple so at the end of the day
even if 0.1 percent of you guys have a
4k display at all
there are little pockets of that
worldwide where it's definitely higher
and i love that so the state of 4k is
strong and even if you can't watch 4k
video if your internet doesn't support
it if you have the opportunity to
upgrade to a 4k tv or display
do it for things like graphic design 4k
gaming
everything is better in 4k
thanks for watching and i'll talk to you
guys in the next one
peace